I do want to follow up on the can Donald
Trump barely read story the background
on this is that we did two viral stories
on Donald Trump's clearly limited
reading ability the videos together got
about a million views on YouTube and
nearly seven million views on Facebook I
was interviewed over the weekend on
radio stations ranging from
Massachusetts to Ireland to be super
clear obviously Donald Trump can read to
some degree you give the guy something
to read
he'll recognize a lot of the words on
the page he can string sentences
together but his reading level is
clearly very low to the point that it's
causing him to adjust his plans on a day
to day basis more on that in a second as
a reminder I won't rehash it now but
I've shown you the deposition video
where Donald Trump clearly is trying to
avoid reading out loud I've shown you
the inauguration day confusion with some
prayers that were handed to him by Mike
Pence at the church he went to before
the inauguration we've talked about a
teleprompter awkwardness we've talked
about him exhibiting all the symptoms of
limited literacy from a Canadian police
checklist on the issue check out those
videos here's the latest which again
only strengthens the case that Trump
really can't read well at all remember
that bizarre situation with the japanese
prime minister shinzo ABI i told you
about earlier in the show where donald
trump pretended to understand japanese
as we covered nodding along to the prime
minister's comments while not having any
earpiece in for translation we focused
on what Shinzo ABI said but what Trump
said or didn't say more importantly
actually tells us a lot Dom Donald Trump
had some prepared remarks to make and
they were captured in a picture by
Reuters as you can see here on this
image this is a document at the top you
can see says POTUS remarks it says a lot
about in the first paragraph Japanese
Defense Forces about a ballistic missile
program several pages Trump didn't read
it it was there he was expected to read
it he just skipped the entire thing and
later a senior administrative official
says oh that was a joint statement that
we decided not to make saying that
basically ocean Zoabi spoke first so
there was no need
Trump to read it it's plausible but
again it continues to build this
unmistakable trend of Trump not reading
out loud if at all possible we've also
now learned and this is where it's just
getting completely over the top pad
we've also now learned about the growing
problem with Donald Trump getting stuff
to read all the time from staffers and
not reading it you know he is the
president sometimes you have to read
stuff and more and more we're learning
that Trump just won't read anything more
than a few bullet points and now there
is some damning new reporting on this
last week I told you that basically
everything had to be reduced to one full
page with eight to ten bullet points for
Donald Trump to read it there's a New
York Times article from yesterday the
latest is that now Donald Trump has to
be given a single page with lots of
graphics and maps and only a few bullet
points even eight to ten bullet points
is too much right now here's a quote
from yesterday's New York Times article
and while mr. Obama liked policy option
papers that were three to six single
spaced pages council staff members are
now being told to keep papers to a
single page with lots of graphics and
maps the president likes maps one
official said we're down to one page and
that page pad is mostly graphics and
maps you simply cannot have the
necessary information to be President if
you boil down every issue to one page
that's mostly pictures and this could be
credited to a lot of different things I
mean maybe it's because he lived a
privileged life that never really had an
incentive to to learn to read in an
appropriate level for him
maybe it's lack of intellectual
curiosity or maybe it's a learning
disability of some sort increasingly
suggested yeah and I mean that would be
of course nothing to make fun of but he
would still have to be open about that
and really he could even turn around to
his advantage and say despite the fact I
have this learning ability I was able to
be elected in this country I mean yeah
what a great story but I think you would
have to show some humility there the
president is basically requesting the
presidential equivalent of picture books
this is what we're dealing with and
and you know because the trumpets are
hugely anti-intellectual list they may
actually see this as some kind of
bizarro strength of sorts but the case
continues to grow that Donald Trump can
barely read